[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Cavaliers select LeBron James there's no
pressure there's no pressure at all I've
been getting pressure since I was 10
years old here he comes the other ways
48 points the last 25 for the Cavaliers
by LeBron James
otherwise
[Applause]
this ball I'm going to take my towns to
South Beach and join the Miami Heat not
two not three not four not five not six
not seven I'm LeBron James from Akron
Ohio from the inner city I'm not even
supposed to be here I'm blessed so what
everybody say about me off the court
don't matter I ain't got no words
[Applause]
LeBron James with a rejection
when I decided to come here you know
just the excitement just to say like
while you're a late organization what
they respect Laker Nation want their
respect and I want my damn respect too
LeBron James is now number two in the
history of the NBA
[Music]
hello Los Angeles
oh no we need more energy than that
hello la
there we go I'll take it my name is
Taylor Brooks I'm so happy to be here
with you guys to celebrate 20 years of
greatness powered by a t5g so I was
prepping for this I was thinking okay 20
years is such a long time first off
raise your hand if you are 20 years old
in here or less
true okay so for you all that are
raising your hands over here he's been
doing this your entire life okay since
2003 the number one box office movie in
2003 was Finding Nemo
the number one song was in the club by
50 Cent okay and Reuben Studdard had
just won American Idol some of you guys
might not even know who we've been
Saturday so it has been a very long time
that LeBron has been doing this so
there's so many highlights so many
blocks so many good shots so many
amazing moments that LeBron has provided
us over the years and we're going to
count down his 20 best highlights but to
do that I need some help I've got my
good friends here with me Mr Channing
Frye and Mr Nick Young give it up for
these two
come on over boys
[Applause]
yeah we going with uh are we going with
Nick or Swaggy P
um I'll swagging you tonight I'm
swagging you're swaggy tonight okay so
you guys know a lot of LeBron highlights
here were actually picked by the fans we
Source it through the BR app over 100
000 users voted in the app so you won't
pick the order of these top 20. it was
not us so I'm very interested uh to see
what kind of came on top what was in the
end so how you feeling I know LeBron is
a very good friend of channing's you
have seen a lot of his career this
moment 20th season what does it
represent I mean the fact that I had the
opportunity to play against him and then
an opportunity to win a championship
with him uh was huge and I did hate
LeBron a lot early on just because I
felt like he was Unstoppable but when
you see the work that he puts in every
day uh you understand why he's had the
longevity there is no player I played
with or seen that is committed to
basketball more than LeBron James I mean
you've heard the stories of he spends a
million dollars a year on his body in
his mind and I'm pretty sure it's more
than that he's uh he's an awesome dude
and he's an even better competitor every
day to we got the opportunity to play
basketball it was you know he turns it
up a little bit yeah
[Applause]
is it about for you Swaggy P what does
this year do you think represent for
LeBron
um longevity like he said be the same
age and he's still flying and I can't
dunk no more so it's like
so uh for me I just to see the work he
put in he's still out there doing it is
unbelievable really absolutely well as
you all know with 20 years of greatness
there's going to be a lot of stuff that
we missed so right now we're going to
show you all the highlights that did not
make the cuts run the tape
okay
yes
61 for LeBron James
[Applause]
guards LeBron jab step three
seven for seven are the Cavaliers
[Applause]
what's going on
you don't ever want to be somebody
else's highlight they get it to LeBron
turnouts on him at three and two LeBron
to win the game
he does
[Applause]
[Music]
missed the cut you all which of those
stick out to you Channing are you
surprised did it make the final 20. no
the one that I thought was the funniest
and like I would say most disrespectful
was when he was spitting the ball
against the Raptors I was on the bench
like no he just did that but he was
already on fire he had already dunked on
somebody we're already putting that
weapon on him so the fact that he was
just spitting the ball in front of his
face like it was like shoot around we
were laughing on a bench uh but just
shows you like when you're in a Zone
like that it doesn't matter what you do
somebody they gonna make it regardless
no absolutely I see I see you laughing
over there you agree yes I didn't know
he was still doing the look at the ball
that young all right it was like a free
throw he just spit it in his hand he was
like okay come get this Serge
okay well let's get into the 20 that did
make it as we said voted on by the fans
uh let's start with those uh what 20 to
16. let's see
[Applause]
here he comes the other way there's your
first James Jam of his career man I
still remember your rookie year that
first game in Sacramento got the
Breakaway done get to the side crowd was
going crazy when he was 18.
congratulations on a terrific terrific
career as you keep going watch this one
wow what a start
but it goes to weight he has Arroyo in
front that battles on a bounce to James
my favorite play probably just comes
down to the one in Milwaukee where D
Wade throws the pass and then he's kind
of has his arms outstretched and
LeBron's flying through there and
dunking it just because of how iconic
that photo was probably makes my
favorite play
[Applause]
er's out to James with a new shot clock
everybody even myself included thought
that ball was going to Kyle Korver right
there for easy three
love long Outlet pass to LeBron he makes
the catch he sets behind the line turn
around three on the way oh
he's got James backed it in with three
tenths of a second remaining he's tied
this game oh my word you have to be
kidding
that's what they came to see now the
fact that he tore down right here
watching people throws it out and he
looks at the guy he says something ah
and then he gets into a little two-step
boom boom like y'all like Joe crowd's
going crazy that right there is a 10 out
of 10.
[Music]
[Applause]
so good one of the things about these
videos is almost as good as the
Highlight is LeBron's reactions and the
crowd reactions and one of the things I
love about that Wizards highlight is the
woman they show is Kamaya Bradley Beal's
wife and she's like I can't believe he
just did this uh to my team the whole
game which is great right and Bradley
Bill had a great game but he definitely
looked at her like and she was like I
hate you LeBron she's the best she's so
funny why are you gonna ask for the ball
right there though hey I thought about
it for a second I was running down I was
like dang I'm open I said ah no no my
paycheck seemed like that but so so I
could be as a competitor right you're
going against LeBron he has one of these
moments what does it do to you
um well I remember when I first got to
the league you know it was saying you
can't do nothing to him on a fast break
you know he was
if you try to follow him he gonna take
you with him to the rim so there's
nothing you can really do and then once
you start getting everything and start
getting the jump shot getting up getting
used to just killing people it was you
couldn't stop him there absolutely so
that first one
was his debut in October 2003 he
finished that one with 25 points and
nine assists did you know
from the moment he came into the league
what he was going to be or did it take
you a minute
I mean the video doesn't know Justice
he's six nine 260 and when I tell you
he's one of the most explosive
especially back then like imagine that
Lakers highlight he was 36 years old so
like to put that into reference like he
used to jump so fast and so violent
there was nothing like our state he
Sinners bounce off of him right it's
that's the thing that is scary about him
and his transformation over the over the
years is that he wasn't supposed to be a
scorer he has an opportunity to beat the
scoring record he could he lead a team
he's taking some of the worst teams to
the NBA finals we may have ever seen
right and so for me
listen I wasn't our team we had some
Hall of favors on there but I'd say if
he's just it's just amazing how athletic
he stayed to be almost 40 years old
absolutely okay we're gonna do a quick
Vive check powered by atnt 5G let's see
what everyone is talking about on the
app when it comes to LeBron looking at
these plays I'll never understand the
hate he gets LeBron clutches player of
all time Braun has some of the most
disrespectful posters ever I have to say
I agree with all three of these comments
why do you think sometimes LeBron gets
the hate that he gets so Agape I think
he's just like because he's like a nice
guy probably they want Superstars that
have that you know that Mama metallic
and then LeBron come off and get along
with everybody but on the court
that side don't come out after about to
take Kareem points you know you can't
because that boy get Buckets you gotta
give him all his respect you know he's
about to be number six on the assist
board so you know I don't think it's
gonna be another LeBron appreciate it
and you cannot stop it okay so more of
this uh Vibe check let's head out to
Pierre Anderson who I know is talking to
some Lakers fans LeBron's fans what up
here
Taylor thank you we here at the Vive
check powered by atnt 5G I'm Pierre from
the through the wild podcast I got a big
LeBron James fan and Trace Trace
obviously we're here count down Lebron's
biggest highlights I gotta ask you
what's your personal favorite LeBron
highlight
well you know I was a Heat fan before I
was a LeBron fan okay and so when he
made the decision to come that was great
for me he's been giving the Celtics hell
for years hopefully uh
so uh my favorite highlight has to be
they were in the back court and Mario
Chalmers got the steal Norris Cole
tosses it up and LeBron yams it on Jason
Terry
shout out to Jason Taylor man hopefully
that highlight does make the list that
is an incredible highlight uh Trace we
want you to enjoy the vibe across the
street at the crypto Arena see LeBron
James up close and personal so we got
two tickets for you man go see that boy
up close to person enjoy the game have
fun Taylor back to you
all right thanks so much fear now you
know what this leads to another point I
want to do a Vibe check in this room
honesty hour okay who was a Lakers fan
big Lakers fan before LeBron got here
okay
who is admittedly a LeBron fan you are
fantasy he your fan now okay see I like
it because I think that a lot of people
are that way which is fine I get it if
my favorite player went somewhere else
you know what do you think when you look
at Lakers fans what majority is pure
LeBron fans or majority is Lakers no the
majority the small stint I had here I
felt the the Lakers Lakers heat it's
amazing Place amazing City uh and that
locker room is special you know I grew
up in Phoenix so I'm a Suns fan but
being able to put that Lakers jersey on
was an honor and uh it just built with
tradition yeah know it's a great fan
base here in Los Angeles with the Lakers
but also I think that LeBron probably
has some of the more um Fierce fans that
exist don't think about saying anything
about LeBron on Twitter on Instagram
they don't come for you I think LeBron
and Steph probably have uh the most
rapid fan bases okay let's get to uh the
rest of the highlights and start with
15.
break away for the cast Gibson
no way
hold Ron there's three seconds left on
the clock you're in the huddle with your
teammates what are you telling them
let's give me the ball
three seconds left Cleveland triggers in
James two seconds one second for the win
[Applause]
that's a winner in Cleveland
the only reason I say this is my
favorite play is because I I called it
out before it happened I remember
watching that game I said bro I'm about
to dunk on somebody
unchanged with no record for human life
and as soon as I said it he in and out
and dunk and I just got hyped like
I told you I know Brian and he came down
the lane and kg was about to jump and he
dunked it that's special to me because I
was like I remember watching it at that
age when I was watching was a player
always stood out to me now that day I
was working with Doug Collins and when
LeBron went up Doug took his arm and
thrusted against my chest and both of
our chairs went backwards and we were in
the lamps of the people in back of his
watching in Cleveland that night
[Applause]
[Music]
my goodness
[Applause]
and just bullets in a powerful Tomahawk
slam check
LeBron James
[Applause]
I love the amount of uh that's crazies
that I'm hearing between you two uh Nick
that one we saw where he finished that
lob from Boobie Gibson that was your
rookie year you didn't play that game I
think it was playoffs it was playoffs
and I'm like this man doing this in
playoffs
and all I remember was my teammate hit
me because I almost got excited like I
was on the team he's like no you can't
do that here you can't do that here well
[ __ ] my bad you know but it was amazing
man it's the stuff you do out there and
you're doing it in a Prime game when the
game was on the line and
this is brown it's brown bro yeah was
there ever a point that you got used to
it I mean he was your teammate you all
are friends but did you get used to
seeing these type of highlight plays
every game you know what I uh you sort
of do and then you see like in the
finals when he starts getting you start
looking at the stat sheet at the end of
the game he has 41 triple doubles he
does that once and then he does it again
and he does it again you're like yo this
man is not human and then his ability to
do that over and over and over again
against the cream of the crop is like is
wild to me it's just like each game
you're like oh well he's not really a
good three-point shooter that makes
seven right it's like well is he gonna
be tired now he's Garden Center so that
was crazy to me it was just like there's
nothing that he is not Elita absolutely
now Nick you you brought it up when you
were a rookie you're seeing LeBron do
these things and you're still amazed
because you just got to the league and
it's you're still digesting the fact
that this is now you know your
competition and one thing that I've
really seen is I'm whether I'm
interviewing jaw or Jason the person
they always say Okay I want to get a
highlight on is LeBron James uh so let's
listen to some of his peers talk about
LeBron
when you think about LeBron you think
about greatness the thing that it's more
admirable like the thing that I love and
the most is how consistent he is always
good for his team you know even though
he win last win last no matter what he
was always there always available if
exceed every expectation everybody put
on him since he was a kid from 80 years
old the fact is going to be the best
brother ever play this game and he he's
damning yeah close he's gonna probably
put like 25 cents
man he's gonna play this play with his
son probably guess this side like it's
crazy they don't think I'm in love with
him bro okay I think some of my favorite
players from his last year
[Applause]
you know I think the dunk on Kevin Love
in year 19 to be able to do that type of
dunk is extremely impressive LeBron
still doing what he does in the year
1920 that he's been doing in year you
know seven is unbelievable
but it was a very dope place because I
was involved in it when he has Kobe for
the most points LeBron
hey NBA's all-time scoring list and
they're throwing him the ball off of
action where he sliced over
um across the block and he got a layup
like that play with definitely another
another big play for me
what's your favorite LeBron play play
I'm gonna say mine I'm gonna say my
block on him on Christmas that's what I
remember six seconds remaining James
step back knocked out of his hands
deflected out of bounds well big bro you
know on the court you know he's been my
rival but you know I give a man his
flowers that man he's done things that
uh every kid every kid grew up want to
do I asked Pat Bell what's his favorite
LeBron highlight over the last 20. this
fool he gonna say the block I had on
no no man what's wrong with Pat pad
what's wrong with Batman
I love that now you know so I could be I
want to give you the floor because I
think you might have a a good LeBron
highlight that actually includes you
know that was a rookie you know and you
know I was going LeBron
he pulled up he looked me up and down
like I was nothing at first he missed it
the ball went kind of far I got the
rebound was me and him on a fast break
he must think I couldn't jump or
something he jumped with me and I ain't
that dunking him he's seen that right
that was nice
that was nice I was short hearing
exactly though
I look up and down though feel you don't
want to do that oh man
I was on clouds I was looking at top 10
all night but they they didn't show it
on there they took the tape and hit it
you know
they you know they gotta have LeBron got
to look good at all times right
um one thing Giannis said that I think
is so important and not always talked
about about LeBron is it's not just that
he's great it's not just that he's been
doing it for 20 years and has this
longevity it's that he became everything
everyone said he was going to be and
that is one of the most difficult things
that you can do not just in sports but
in life I mean he's had constant
pressure constant expectations and he
continues to surpass them why do you
think
I just think he and I try to say this as
much as possible as basketball players
some of us play trying to earn minutes
or trying to win that game or try to be
an All-Star Lebron from the age of 16
was like I'm trying to be the best
player ever so he looks at the game a
lot differently when he gets the
schedule he's looking at okay I need to
switch my diet up during this time
because we're playing more games or I
need this guy to be this good because
this team has done this like the bronze
brain works in a way that I have never
seen maybe two guys have had brains like
that at Grant Hill and Steve Nash right
and so those guys are all famous for me
for LeBron to come into the league
average what he did and continue that
for up for 20 years is crazy and there
has never been another player with more
pressure from the age of 15 16 than
LeBron and nobody more documented we
know every single part of LeBron's life
we know his family we know everything
and I think that's why some sometimes he
gets as much hate as he is because he's
not hiding away who he is or what he
believes or his opinions and so whether
you like them or not he's like this is
what I think and so people are going to
take that and that's just you know a
theory in life absolutely and Nick I
mean all of us up here know that it
takes a lot for NBA players to make
their bodies their success a full-time
job talk about the discipline that
LeBron is practicing day in and day out
um LeBron the money spent on his body
just says it all you know you spend that
much on your body you got to be in the
right mental state
um I didn't have that much money to
spend on my body
you know I couldn't do that so I worked
with what I had you know but uh for
somebody like LeBron to come in with
that much pressure people was talking
about him because he had a Hummer in
high school they didn't want him to be
who he was and now 20 years later you
know he's the greatest you know one of
the greatest
it was that was the thing in the Hummer
um okay uh let's uh keep the countdown
going more highlights please
[Applause]
when I first saw it I said you know what
that's an accident so I had to rewind
this play one time two times three times
by the fourth time I said okay he meant
to do that that's why he's King James
put it down
my favorite Brian cliff ever has to be
when he's a Cleveland and a donkey out
of James Johnson against Chicago
[Applause]
that was just like just a force and how
high he was that was probably the crazy
highlight and that's probably my
favorite one ever
[Applause]
no timeouts remaining for Cleveland now
and they've got the ball
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
to be able to do that and my guys they
trust me
[Applause]
the greatest shot block of all time that
I've seen was probably LeBron in the NBA
finals
[Applause]
from James
that was an amazing Vlog came out of
nowhere got it at the rim Thiago was
just about to put it through through the
ceilings and he got it at the rim you
could see Brian's arm like almost bent
back and push it out so that was
exciting and the strength of LeBron
James to stop this and throw
[Applause]
it one second to play he gets it to
LeBron for three for the win yeah
I remember most I've had to watch it
Time After Time After Time for the last
13 years around playoff time if I had
had my defender on the ball tracking
LeBron James we might have been able to
take that shot away that's what MVPs do
those kind of shots
[Applause]
a lot of players and coaches have some
what ifs if only if only we have done
this I don't know how much you would uh
stopped it there but that's that was
2009 game two and he was actually coming
off a 49 point performance in game one
in that final highlight that we saw
another reminder these were all fan
voted over a hundred thousand fans voted
in the app for these highlights for the
order how do you think the fans have
done so far in their selection I think
it's great I think people underestimate
what a disrespectful game winner that is
against Toronto never in my 20 38 39
years Years of Living have I seen
somebody shoot a runner going left with
his right hand over two Defenders
offline like I just you're like how do
you have the audacity to shoot that like
like of all the shots it wasn't like you
don't practice that right and so it just
shows you like you're just like man he
on a different level yeah and I feel
like LeBron is uh not short on Audacity
uh did you have that same thought about
that I think that year he should have
won MVP he was just the team he had he
took him to the finals and what he did
to Toronto that series is crazy
okay now I have to ask you know there's
always the debate about the years LeBron
should have won MVP but didn't has four
how many should LeBron have
how many MVPs should LeBron have
I'ma say
six to seven
six or seven
six or seven he's had some amazing years
where I think sometimes we take things
for granted
um and his effect on winning and and the
way he uplifts his teammates uh but you
know hey I think one year the Year
somebody got defensive play of the year
I thought he was actually trying that
year so he should have got it uh he was
different that year on defense too uh
that yeah Marcus old got it yeah he was
a an absolute animal uh but I mean he's
always in a run for something right he's
always top three in MVP top two and
defensive player all right Nick so
Channing says six or seven how many MVPs
should LeBron have man um foreign
honestly they could have gave it to him
every year if they wanted to but I feel
like it could have at least
12.
until up into his career oh for sure for
sure but it would have been born to just
see him win each year each year so
the thing to be said about when you kind
of become the standard right and like
the expectation everybody wants you to
be that every year it's like you said
they take for granted what he's doing
year in and year out because the
greatness has become synonymous with
LeBron and that's one of the reasons
that we we enjoy watching him I think we
have another vibe check powered by a t
5G let's check in with the commenters on
the app I don't know how you can watch
these highlights not call him the goat
that is Leland Ferguson we agree imagine
if LeBron did a dunk cut Dunk Contest uh
see this is so cool seeing what his
legacy means to other players too yeah I
agree with that and I think that's one
of the really cool things Channing is
you know for these young guys LeBron has
always been everything he's probably one
of the reasons some of them are playing
basketball have you experienced that
just in your conversations with other
players yeah definitely I think it's you
when you take a step back and after
you're done playing with him and you go
to other teams they're like well what
does he do and how much does he work out
in and they're like trying to get the
paper and I was like dude just call him
like reach out to him they'll tell you
and I've seen a lot of players try to
keep up with him like oh man I want to
do what LeBron does and I've seen them
fade faster than a wet paper airplane
like it's it is wild to see but again
he's like inspiring the Next Generation
whether it's on or off the court and
people to uh Elevate the game and be
total players absolutely all right Vibe
check we're powered by 18 t5g let's go
back to Pierre what's up
thanks Taylor we back with another vibe
check powered by atnt 5G I'm here with
lay lay we count down LeBron's greatest
moments and highlights so I have to know
what's your personal favorite highlight
greatest moment oh when he won the
championship when he came to the Lakers
2020
it's a wrap you was at the parade parade
everything okay lay hopefully that
highlight make the list an incredible
highlight for sure we want you to
continue The Vibes across the street at
the crypto Arena so we got you two
tickets to go see LeBron and Lakers up
close and personal enjoy the game have
fun Taylor back to you
thanks so much Pierre I love that okay
so for everybody in here we have reached
the top five highlights are you all
ready
all right let's do it uh let's start
with number five
favorite play Byron he got so many plays
man it's hard to just choose one the
reverse dunk he did with the Lakers
that was just like Kobe's it's probably
my favorite play
[Applause]
thank you
know if I had a favorite I think I would
say it is that one too that was less
than two weeks after Kobe passed and it
was such a beautiful tribute to him what
do you remember about watching that
moment Nick
for me yeah and when you see the side by
side you get more emotional it makes the
dunk look more ten times better it's
just a dope moment for basketball being
in the moment
when when La in the world was mourning
you know
I think that was that was dope that was
dope no for sure and for you I think
also just knowing and having that
presence of mind to do what was the best
tribute for Kobe it's wild most people
are like oh man let me just make a layup
he's like let me go into my memory bank
of a Kobe dunk that I could emulate as
we're playing a live game it just shows
you his mind is is working a thousand
times like the game of basketball is so
slow to him like I know people if
they've seen me talk about them or
Richard or shop like his mind is
literally a computer the first day I got
traded here uh to Cleveland I was like
man you remember that time I cooked you
in Phoenix and he was like what game and
so I was like well remember that time we
beat y'all when you were at the heat he
goes y'all only beat us in 2011 and you
had this many points and I guarded you
here it was crazy he was like the only
time it was because the rotation was
slow from the top of the key and then I
switched on you then you didn't score
the rest of the game so I said man get
out of here I went and checked the tape
it was literally everything was
absolutely correct he was calling out
our plays from 2011. this is 2016. now
it's like man you def you're different
and we've seen those moments Nick like
in the press conferences where someone
asked him a question and he tells us
exactly what happened uh do you have a
story similar like similar to that no I
never really got a chance to play with
LeBron I just
played against someone you know hear
them call out things I was going to do
and I'm like how you know I was gonna go
that way you know he laughed about it
you're just gonna [ __ ] he knew I wasn't
gonna pass it in the bed so you're so
you're saying you're playing against
LeBron LeBron says to you what you are
about to do and he still did it
[Laughter]
the story and I think it's either
Detroit or Toronto one of the guys
wasn't paying attention and Coach called
out a play LeBron I'm right there next
to him LeBron's like hey man you gotta
stand in the corner go across set the
screen to the to his team he's like oh
thanks man literally does the play
LeBrons again man set the screen but not
really then it's going to go up and do
this and I'm like hey yo no way sure
enough does that thing and we're like
come on and I think even DeRozan was
like man that's different for him to
know everybody on the court all the time
it's crazy no crazy presence of mine
okay uh let's look at number four
crazy LJ 20 years with the highlights
you've given us been unbelievable
unfortunately I've been part of one of
them highlighters I'm reminded of it all
the time when I'm walking around how did
it feel when LeBron jumped over you in
Miami oh he does it again and he goes
right over Lucas I didn't even see that
on the play originally it was like a
step ladder
that was a hell of a play my guy keep
going salute
[Applause]
I mean does it get more yikes than that
real quick on that one don't let him
replay it don't let him replay it as a
one man to another you gotta say
something to him you got the amen I got
kids you cannot put me on a poster like
that you can't just jump over me you at
least gotta act like you're gonna fight
yeah
no Nick if that's you in that moment
tell me what you do right after me oh
man I'm at least gonna throw the ball at
him at the back of him or something I'm
gonna get a tank somehow
I don't need to be in the game anymore
take the shoes off that's it if you get
jumped over two feet though he's another
two feet over me where do you think that
ranks overall just in terms of
disrespectful posters
that's up there with Vince Carter well
no I mean it's different because he's
probably six foot and Vince jumped over
a seven footer but one human being
jumping the one grown man jumping over
another grown man is is extremely
disrespectful you got yourself and
honestly and I hopefully you guys get
what I'm saying when I say this
him not like falling is almost worse
you know because it's like no I
basically cleared you to get to get to
the bathroom you're like man just jumped
off like Super Mario I was like come on
man just like hit the ground so it's
like listen there was a lot of a lot of
touch a lot of compact
um I love that but shadow to John still
being a good sport about it through all
these years all right we're almost done
you all number three
[Applause]
LeBron was in Cleveland and they was
playing in Detroit in the playoffs she
wrote that game like he went crazy he
actually had to get an IV I think after
that game but I was there I drove down
to Detroit you know because it was just
so crazy to see all the shots that he
was making James has the fire
he has scored in the last 25 points for
Cleveland scores
[Applause]
Victory 48 points probably one of the
games I never forget
22 years old in that highlight ended
ended that game with 48 points nine
rebounds seven assists 22. I think that
that Detroit Pistons team is one of the
most underrated Champions defensively
they were demons and when he started
going off versus those grown men and
Duncan like that I said oh you you
different I say he he is that in
everything like that John C Billups Hall
of Famer you look at Ben Wallace Hall of
Fame when she was and he was just there
was nothing they were double teaming him
all over the court anywhere he wanted to
get to he got to and with just 25
straight points in the NBA once you go
on a streak of 12 14 you're getting a
double team right so 25 in a row now
you're getting triple teamed he's still
barbecuing them
I see you watching those when you think
about that that finals right there what
really sticks out the most
um like you see here the crazy things
where people say you don't have like an
offensive bag and then you look at that
you see the crossover you see the behind
the back
see three people guarding on me still
get to the hole like it's unbelievable
like the hate he gives and people say he
he can't score and you look at this and
it's
it's crazy what do you think is the most
underrated aspect of LeBron's game Nick
um I would say it's handled you know I
didn't see LeBron Crossing people over
until I already started paying attention
you know but he had somebody at the top
of the key he did it between the legs
crossover
um I would say it's handled to be that
big to be that strong
you know
yeah what do you think it's definitely
his handle I think you saw that clip of
when he went behind the back underneath
Tristan's legs so James Harden was doing
that in in Houston and so Braun will see
something that another Elite player is
doing and gets his little computer mind
going and he was practicing that with
trust me right so he was practicing
doing that move over and over and over
again because teams are showing really
hard and trying to get back so he was
practicing that and then like usually
you practice him for a week two weeks
you practice it one time and it did it
in a game and I'm like come on man like
you're not gonna work on that a little
bit more nope it goes and does it that
same day that he decided he was going to
work on it absolutely okay we're uh
nearing the end let's look at number two
my favorite LeBron play I always say the
alley-oop in Boston Jason Terry
my favorite LeBron play would have to be
the live he called on Jason Terry I hate
to do it to Jet but the the lob against
Boston on Jason but that's that's
probably my favorite that was crazy
[Applause]
and that stared him down
[Applause]
and of course they won that game it was
their 23rd win in a row and it was
eventually a 27 game winning streak
which I believe is the second longest
streak uh winning streak in the NBA do
you guys remember this one pretty
vividly I'm sure yeah JT is a U of A guy
so where I was watching I was I got a
weird sense of humor I still crack up to
this day watching it just how we fell he
fell like a baby falling down the stairs
just laid there
it was just disrespectful yeah it was
just so and I asked jet like what were
you thinking he was like man I didn't
know who jumped till it was too late
he thought it was uh he thought it was
Mario Chalmers and he got he got the big
fell
you know after this LeBron talked about
how happy he was that it was jet he said
because Jet's a trash talker and it was
like I'm happy that it was him I know
you all have talked about LeBron calling
out plays and things like that but is
LeBron also a trash talker or is he just
more like I'm gonna show you I think
he's more of a show you but like when it
comes to these Arizona guys they talk a
lot and he just gotta like you gotta
show him you know and that's gonna be on
YouTube Forever everywhere his kids
gonna see that so I'm happy that
happened to somebody that went to
Arizona you know hey trust me I don't
know about the Arizona guys if I could
dunk on janning I would
I'm proud of you
hey all right you guys we have one more
what do you all think it is feel free to
call it out what do you think
oh I got a lot of people saying the
block and they might be right let's look
at number one
probably the favorite one is the block
against Golden State I think that was a
pretty amazing place
[Applause]
third block of the game LeBron's
blocking the finals it was amazing you
know like he got back and transitioned
and then to make a play like that on
that stage incredible if I'd have to say
that block in the finals versus Golden
State on Iguodala no protecting both
sides of the rim I'm not that he's the
only person in the road that can make
that play and you know that's what makes
him you know Second To None you know
arguably the greatest player to ever
play the game
I mean there was no other choice right
definitely not I have never seen a human
move that fast
I thought he looked like a demon out
there because I was watching Jr but
during that year Jr had a problem
fouling guys so Braun kept yelling at
him just make him do make them so he
can't just dunk it and so that's what Jr
swam by so I'm on the bench I got the
best seat in the house and I just see
this black bird go by my face I was like
what is that and for him to have the the
wherewithal to not hang on the rim to to
not foul Andre and to just keep the ball
in play is a wild it's just not normal
it's just not regular people regular NBA
players most All-Stars can't do that and
that was just one of the wildest moments
I was on the bench like man let me go to
the back I'm not going to play I'm gonna
have a heart attack out here that was
one of the craziest games I've ever
watched in my life and uh ended with
some uh some Hardware Channing
Nick
now Nick you know that it's a good
highlight when it has its own Wikipedia
page the block has a Wikipedia page do
you think the first line of that
Wikipedia pages
the block period period all you need
when you go back to the locker room what
are y'all talking about that has to be
one of the main things okay I'm talking
about how drunk we're gonna get on this
champagne I'm gonna tell you that right
now we um you know we were exhausted
right the the focus it took to come back
from 3-1
and that team was so good when we were
watching film we were like man I think
it was like we made five mistakes in the
first half and they scored 15 points
like that's how good golden state is is
that we had to play Perfect Kyrie had to
go crazy people forget about Kevin Love
blacking out and guarding Steph Curry
I've never seen him play defense since
and then that block it was just everyone
had to do their jobs to the best of
their ability and everyone knew
everyone's plays uh so when we got back
man it was just like exhaustion even for
me because based on paychecks I knew I
wasn't going to play in these games so
the emotions you get sitting on the
bench
they need a free throw shooter I'm good
put me in coach I can do that all right
I have a question for the audience we
have heard from a lot of different
players around the league about their
favorite LeBron moments should we hear
from LeBron about his favorite moment
you think
all right let's see what LeBron had to
say about LeBron
my favorite moment man I think it's
probably my first make
the first make that I had in Sacramento
and that Baseline Fade Away by our bench
LeBron James first shot is good that's
that was the start of it yeah that was
the moment where I was like oh man I can
do this like I can really do this at the
first shot that I made in this league
you know really really told me I was
like okay I'm here now let's rock
I love that he had 25 points in that
debut obviously went on to win rookie of
the year that is still the most points
uh by a prep to Pro so definitely an
iconic moment but I also think it was
the easy answer from LeBron also
sometimes I've made my first shot and I
made the rest of him he was like yeah I
could be an All-Star NBA off of one
mid-range jumper that's different right
sometimes I make the first one that rims
shrink down to a keyhole I'm like yeah I
don't know if I belong here but I'ma
stay as long as I can yeah listen you
got nobody else to put in you know I
think that the fans did a really really
good job voting first off give it up for
yourselves uh for these highlights was
there any major major ones they missed
that weren't also in the beginning
there's some missed dunks that he had uh
against so against the Portland
Trailblazers he missed an alley-oop
because he hit his head on the backboard
do you remember that yeah it is just
catch it which is crazy and then in that
Finals game after the block after all
that when he tried to dunk on Draymond
and got fouled I had his head was up by
the rim and he had already played 46
minutes and so for him to go up that
high at that point of the game was great
like it was one of the best misses I've
ever seen for sure obviously as we say
20 years of greatness they have all been
fabulous I know we all wish there could
be 20 more but there won't be what do
you think the league is going to be like
without LeBron
oh man it's gonna be tough you know
because
LeBron brings a lot you know and every
time I a Jordan Lee if you get a Kobe
Kobe leave you can get LeBron and Kobe
at the same time but
it's gonna be hard you know it's gonna
be hard to see Lebron leave you know but
as long as he keep paying his money for
his body he might be here a little bit
longer you know like maybe we do get 20
right that'd be Tom Brady here right
yeah so there's a live look at LeBron
across the street you know that that
game is coming I do want us to look to
the Future for one second let's say in
20 years we all are back together who's
another player you can see us doing 20
years of greatness highlight package
Channing
maybe Giannis
I just think he's dedicated to the game
like that but we're never gonna see
anyone
who what LeBron is doing uh I think
somebody told me
somebody would have to start going to
the playoffs when they were 18 and
average 23 for 20 years to even be close
to what he's doing so like that's what's
crazy it's like the consistency at the
the highest level regular season stuff I
know a lot of players that could do
regular season stuff and give regular
season awards he's different when they
put the real lights on and that's what's
been amazing especially for a guy that
isn't a scorer but is going to break the
scoring record this year you know knock
on wood and all that kind of stuff got
to make some more threes but you know
I mean everyone on that team got to make
some more threes
um for you all watching at home make
sure you flip on over to TNT Clippers
Lakers everybody that was in this room
thank you so much for your energy for
being here we appreciate it
um and also second half NBA Twitter live
me and Channing and Jamal Crawford will
be talking over the game over there at
uh crypto Arena which I always still
want to call it Staples yes
thank you so much Nick thanks Channing
thank you all enjoy the game
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]